la agencia para los refugiados de
naciones unidas ha declarado que la
emergencia en ucrania por la guerra es
el nivel 3 el más alto del que dispone
esta agencia más de 4.6 millones de
personas han huido del país según las
más recientes cifras en visita en vista
de esta rapidez con la que evoluciona la
crisis humanitaria en ucrania acnur está
colaborando con las autoridades agencias
de la onu y grupos comunitarios de
personas desplazadas y socios para así
brindar asistencia humanitaria también
en varios países de europa hay
centenares de voluntarios que abren sus
casas a los refugiados ucranianos
alegando que si el gobierno no pueda
cogerlos lo hacen ellos en los países
vecinos acnur también ha enviado
expertos en emergencias y reservas de
suministros y ayuda como mantas térmicas
colchonetas para que se distribuyan a
las personas refugiadas sin embargo no
es suficiente y más allá de esto no son
lugares para acoger a cientos de miles
de personas por un tiempo prolongado por
ello entonces quiero darle la bienvenida
a nuestra primera invitada del día ella
es una mangana directora de la catedral
islam de la universidad católica de
uruguay y también analista política
internacional susana qué bueno tenerla
nuevamente con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 pero más allá de
tenerla como la directora de la cátedra
del slam y también analista política
internacional la tenemos aquí como una
persona más que se ha sumado a los
esfuerzos de todos los civiles que se
han volcado a ayudar a las personas se
en ucrania los refugiados que salen
huyendo de la catástrofe de una guerra
tan cruel como la que hemos visto en
nuestras imágenes desde que comenzó esta
invasión en ese país susanna un abrazo
que tal raúl cómo estás bueno el abrazo
también es recíproco porque creo que en
estas horas nada más regresar de lo que
ha sido esta misión nos hace falta a
todos un abrazo ha sido ha sido bastante
duro lo que hemos visto allí pero
también lo que se vive en un viaje así
porque no es un viaje de placer
obviamente y tampoco lo es el sentirte
responsable de por lo menos por unas
horas y por unos días inicialmente de la
suerte de esas personas que saliendo de
un país en guerra
saben tienen la incertidumbre de a dónde
llegar tienen una idea tienen un
contacto pero no saben a qué país van no
saben realmente en el sentido de que no
saben con qué se van a encontrar y eso
es un peso hay una responsabilidad que
hay que tomarlo como tal es una
responsabilidad enorme raúl y susana le
pregunta la situación de los refugiados
en todos estos campamentos las
condiciones precarias en las que se
encuentran pues si bien es cierto el
trato ha sido bueno pues no están por
supuesto estas estructuras y estos
campamentos diseñados para albergarlos
por un largo tiempo
por supuesto que no son expoferias son
lugares grandes que normalmente se
utilizan para hacer exposiciones o para
hacer algún tipo de feria de marketing o
por ejemplo a stands de una feria
de turismo exponer allí alimentos o
exponer por ejemplo pues todo lo que
tiene que ver con expo ferias en el
mundo verdad pero no dejan de ser
lugares de chapa lugares precarios como
tú dices que suele hacer mucho frío
incluso dentro cuando llueve cuando hay
nieve fuera por supuesto que ahora nos
vamos adentrando también en la primavera
en polonia nos sorprendió que no hacía
tanto frío en la frontera donde
estuvimos con ucrania como habíamos
esperado pero eso depende mucho de la
climatología lo que realmente es frío es
lo que se puede palpar adentro porque
hay muchísimas personas que están
esperando abordar un autobús viven pues
como pueden no en camastros que son
improvisados que tienen mantas sí pero
que muchas veces no pueden ni siquiera
ducharse porque como me decían muchas de
las muchachas con las que pude viajar y
hablar me decían no me sentía cómoda
teniendo que desnudarme delante de otras
mujeres no no me pude duchar durante
equis días
estaba fría los niños no querían bañarse
entonces si viene solidaridad si bien
hay alimento asegurado también hay que
tener en cuenta que son muchas personas
transitando por un mismo lugar no hay
suficiente desinfección o higiene de los
baños de las mantas de los alimentos con
los que se alimenta estas personas y por
eso empiezan a surgir problemas
digestivos estomacales no los niños
empiezan a tener vómitos luego diarrea
todo esto genera una serie de virus o de
gastritis a veces más severa que afecta
incluso a aquellos que van a subirse a
un autobús como nos ha tocado vivir raúl
claro y que circulan también en ese
ambiente susana le pregunto entonces
usted que tú estuvo en el terreno usted
que estuvo en estos albergues digamos
para estos refugiados pues han sido las
historias más impactantes las que más le
marcaron en esta misión
en realidad no te voy a decir uno a la
distancia creo que va a ir allí incluso
me imagino que los periodistas piensan
que van a ir y sacar una nota de este
tipo siempre vas a poder encontrar notas
de color muy desgarradoras muy
llamativas pero ahí no era mi objetivo
ese no hubo tiempo tampoco de sentarse a
conversar con ellos en esos centros
luego si en el autobús había muchas
horas de viaje pero créeme que uno
intenta ponerse en el lugar por lo menos
intento ponerme en el lugar de esa
persona y no quieres sonsacar no querer
averiguar que han visto que han visto de
negativo porque todos te dicen de qué
ciudad vienen y uno si están
medianamente informado te das cuenta que
han tenido que salir porque realmente lo
están que saben invadido su ciudad o su
pueblo o porque su familia había
decidido poner a resguardo a los niños
más pequeños ya las mujeres más jóvenes
algunas también no tan jóvenes entonces
historias desgarradoras es haber
escuchado con una mujer joven tuvo que
pasar un mes y medio escondida en un
sótano con muy poco alimento otra
historia desgarradora es saber que una
abuelita de 106 años perdón 96 años que
ya son muchos 96 años que viajó con
nosotros bueno a su familia preocupada y
luego quería tenerla aquí y como ella
sola no podía valerse para el viaje
tuvieron que traer a una hija y otros
familiares para poder asistir la en este
viaje pero eso realmente es un riesgo
también para la vida de esa persona pero
para aquellos que hacen este tipo de
periplo y de eso también quiero hablar
raúl que está muy bien que haya
iniciativa solidaria espíritu decía al
principio kudrow acnur las grandes
agencias que están en este tipo de
catástrofes humanitarias pero mi
impresión cuando vuelvo del terreno es
que no hay gobierno en esos centros de
refugiados y lamento muchísimo la
ausencia total y absoluta de delegados
de gobiernos de europa que son los que
están recibiendo esta cantidad de
refugiados no hay una mísera mísera
representación de ninguna cancillería
europea no lo he podido ver tampoco he
visto oficinas de acnur allí sí mucha
gente joven voluntaria algunos
latinoamericanos que atienden en el
stand por ejemplo de españa por llamarlo
de alguna manera no llega a ser un
estante es un mostrador improvisado con
muy buena voluntad pero totalmente
desbordados entonces hay que llamar la
atención una vez más a las autoridades
responsables
de lo que es el tránsito de personas y
la llegada a territorio francés sueco
español porque tienen que hacerse
presentes y tienen que apoyar con medios
con financiación y con personal y tienen
que apoyar este tipo de centros de
refugiados porque desde allí parten los
autobuses no importa quién los flete
quién los organice pero hay que darse
cuenta que la vida de estas personas
también está en riesgo incluso durante
los viajes y hay que poner medios por
ejemplo enfermeros que puedan acompañar
a estas personas durante el viaje porque
nos ha tocado hacer de eso llevar algo
de medicinas básicas de venta libre en
farmacia pero eso no es suficiente
cuando una persona que una bajada de
tensión cuando una persona tiene un
problema del corazón y no se sabe
previamente cuando los niños vomitan
mucho y hay que parar en medio del
camino para ir a un hospital en francia
en alemania de emergencias así que por
favor utilizo este medio para llamar al
orden a esos responsables de distintos
ministerios de asuntos exteriores en
europa para que envíen delegados de una
buena vez porque como tú dices la
emergencia está lejos de terminar claro
y
diciendo usted
me surgen muchas preguntas como quién
líder entonces estos albergues y además
cuando las personas van allá pues
obviamente quieren un tipo de
información que hacer hacia qué país van
como pues acogerse al plan de la unión
europea para este permiso de trabajo de
residencia temporal o sea eso es un
territorio sin ley digamos que quien le
da esa información a un refugiado que
llega y cómo se van organizando porque
es bien grave lo que estás diciendo a
susana
es muy grave y por eso decidí dar la
nota te juro que dudé hasta el último
momento que yo no estoy bien de ánimo
después de todo lo que he visto y lo que
he vivido en estas últimas horas no
estoy bien pero es una responsabilidad
moral y hay que hacerlo bien hasta el
final o intento hacerlo y ser sobre todo
humana con lo que está pasando y yo creo
que es lamentable estas personas lo que
quieren es subirse a un autobús lo están
pensando en cómo es la ley como tengo
que hacer si tienen preguntas pero allí
no se las van a poder responder por
tanto no puede ser que voluntarios
jovencitos de veintipocos años tengan
que cargar con toda esa responsabilidad
que a su vez se ven achuchados y digo
esa palabras se ven agobiados por la
cantidad de personas que les preguntan
día y noche cuando me puedo ir tengo que
ir aquí allí entonces lo prioritario
allí es darles albergue transitorio pero
también sacarlos cuanto antes porque hay
gente que quiere marcharse que dice
tener un contacto y que luego tú te das
cuenta que ese contacto no responde que
es el número de móvil no hay persona que
responda o que finalmente te dicen voy a
ir a barcelona o málaga ya gire por
ejemplo a cruz roja bueno eso tiene que
trabajarse mejor tiene que haber
representación de estas organizaciones
grandes que son las que tienen
estructura y financiación no me sirven
excusas porque no pueden estar allí en
el terreno y después tiene que haber
representación de los gobiernos sobre
todo los países de la unión europea
susana y estas personas digamos hablamos
de estas que ustedes ayudaron a sacar en
estos tres autobuses hasta territorio
español qué va a pasar con ellas a dónde
van estas personas bueno por suerte cada
caso es diferente pero muchos de ellos
son de lo que llamamos niños de
chernóbil aquí en el país vasco pero
también los hay en madrid que tienen
familias de acogida que durante ya
muchos años los han tratado entonces
esas familias se han puesto a la
disposición de estas ongs o de estas
iniciativas solidarias de la ciudadanía
para acoger a esos niños que hoy muchos
han crecido incluso tienen hijos ellos y
entonces esas personas van a tener un
domicilio estable y una acogida acorde
no digna digna y que se preocupen por
ellos y por todos los documentos que van
a tener que tramitar porque tampoco es
inmediato una cosa es lo que dice el
espíritu de la norma y otra cosa es el
día a día y el tener que esperar un
turno o tener que ir
realizar trámites por supuesto que
tienen un trato muy diferente también a
otro refugiado recordemos que hay sirios
afganos o colombianos que no tienen ese
tipo de privilegio pero en el caso de
los ucranianos que es de lo que hoy me
estás preguntando también hay personas
que vienen por ejemplo con destino a
málaga destino a valencia granada porque
tienen allí algún familiar o tiene algún
contacto y presumen o entienden que van
a poder ser asistidos por esa persona
desde nuestro lugar lo que hemos hecho
es contactar a esas personas verificar
que existen verificables están esperando
que es cierta la información para no
dejarlos también solos y desamparados en
territorio desconocido porque además del
idioma hay otro tipo de impedimentos el
idioma después de todo con un traductor
en nuestros dispositivos móviles se
puede solventar en caso de emergencia
pero otras cuestiones no entonces
se asiste de la mejor manera pero
insisto hay mucho voluntarismo pero
mucha desorganización y eso muchas veces
atenta contra una misión humanitaria que
aún teniendo la mejor de las voluntades
no siempre termina bien claro susana
hablemos de la situación de los niños de
los menores de edad cómo es el proceso
de estos niños para entrar a la unión
europea como refugiados no sé si a lo
mejor también usted tuvo la oportunidad
de llevar a unos niños a un lugar en
españa' o una familia que los acoge como
cientos de familias españolas y europeas
en varios países que están acogiendo
estos menores de edad huérfanos
bueno no son huérfanos los que yo he
visto y no hay el trámite con estos
huérfanos quiero creer que va a ser
diferente deseo de todo corazón que sea
diferente
los niños que yo puedo ver tanto en los
centros de refugio que visité como
también los que han abordado estos tres
autobuses que vinieron con nosotros
vienen acompañados por sus madres o sus
hermanas y entonces están acompañados
por alguien que por más que sea joven ya
son adultos y 1920 años pero esa es la
edad de los adultos a veces 19 años y
con un hijo o 18 años y a cargo de una
de una niña hermana menor entonces esas
personas suben al autobús en lo que sí
te puedo decir es que lo que parecería
algo que facilita la misión que es
transitar desde alemania a francia sin
presentarte ante ningún control aduanero
y eso parece que es muy auspicioso
también es muy riesgoso porque porque
así como puede haber personas de bien
que están haciendo una misión queriendo
llevar a esas personas a un territorio
seguro puede pero otros desalmados que
utilicen esa misma facilidad para
trasladar personas y por eso es
importante y urgente que las
instituciones que tienen esa
responsabilidad se hagan presentes en el
lugar y ahora que he estado allí te
puedo decir que no escucho más
embustes y más patrañas y más excusas
menos funcionarios en bruselas y por
favor que estén más presentes en los
centros de refugiados para cumplir ya
nuestra conversación susana que
reflexión puede hacer tiene 50 segundos
que una guerra siempre es muy trágica es
muy triste y que es inhumano en el siglo
21 tengamos que ver a personas de 96
años 80 años abandonar su hogar sabiendo
que quizás ya nunca más sin él quizás
nunca más van a volver a él y que además
las estamos obligando a un exilio
forzoso sea polonia o sea alemania o sea
españa donde no se van a poder integrar
bien a esa edad y que es muy triste ver
como un pueblo se ha visto invadido y
obligado a al exilio por la locura y la
geopolítica de personas que no tienen en
cuenta a sus pueblos